[MUSIC PLAYING]
Compressed image formats
like PNG, JPEG, and WebP
do a fantastic job of reducing
the file size of your images
for distribution and transfer.
But once the images get off
the disk and into memory,
all those great compression
savings disappear.
My name is Colt McAnlis, and
serious application developers
know that smaller images don't
have to stop with disk formats.
With the help of some of
Android's built in features,
you can reduce the
amount of heap space
that your images
are taking up, which
can improve memory
efficiency and performance.
It's worth pointing out that
the Dalvik version of Android's
garbage collector
is non-compacting,
meaning that as
objects are freed,
other objects will not be
shuffled around in order
to optimize for free space.
This represents a large
problem for bitmaps,
which tend to be the largest
continuous blocks of memory
that you'll actually
allocate in your app.
The less contiguous free
space there is in your heap
means that allocations
for bitmaps
can fail, causing a
garbage collection
event to be kicked off
in order to free up
space in other places so that
the allocation can eventually
succeed or throw an
out of memory error.
The reason that these images
are so large in memory
is that before you can
use JPEG or PNG files,
they first have to
be loaded into memory
and decompressed to a
format that the system can
use for rendering, meaning
that once they're loaded,
they aren't in their
compressed form anymore.
Nope, they're sitting
around on your CPU memory
in all of their
uncompressed glory.
And by default, when
images are loaded
into a bitmap in
Android, they're
done so at 32 bits per
pixel, giving eight bits
to each of the red, green,
blue, and alpha channels.
This happens even if you're
loading an image without alpha,
like a JPEG image.
Currently, Android
doesn't have support
for 24 bits per
pixel image formats,
meaning that even if your
image doesn't use alpha,
when it's loaded, it'll get
converted to a 32-bit format
in memory, basically weighting
eight bits per pixel.
Oh, and don't forget that before
these images can be rendered
to the screen, they first have
to be transferred to the GPU
as textures, which means
that each bitmap you create
is going to be taking
up CPU memory and GPU
memory at the same time.
In order to address
these problems,
Android supports a few
alternate pixel formats
that when used properly
can provide smaller
CPU and GPU footprints, leading
to less heap fragmentation
and better performance.
Of course, the trick here is
that the savings of the space
comes at the cost of
visual quality, which
means that these
formats may not be
right for every single scenario.
For example, utilizing
the RGB565 format
allows you to use
only 16 bits per pixel
and ignore allocating any
bits to the alpha channel.
Of course, you've now cut the
amount of information per pixel
in half, which
reduces the number
of possible unique
colors in your image.
This is most noticeable in
gradient areas of your images
or in icons, but
for most photos,
the difference is really
hard to notice, especially
on a very tiny screen.
Now, if you want smaller format
but you still need alpha,
trying the 4444 image
format, which basically
cuts the number of
bits per pixel in half
and keeps the alpha
channel, but of course
introduces larger
visual differences.
This lower quality
means that you're
going to end up with
significant banding in areas
of the image that
have smooth gradients.
So it's not really appropriate
for full screen high resolution
photos, but it can easily work
as a format for thumbnails that
might need some alpha
applied to them,
like if you're baking in
rounded corners to your images
or something like that.
Now, while Android doesn't
support gray scale bitmaps,
the Alpha8 format can still be
quite used for alpha masking.
For instance, creating a
simple grey icon and then using
a color tint at run time to
turn it into the color that you
actually want on the screen.
You'll get a little
extra overhead
during the rendering
of your image,
but this might be a
huge win with respect
to memory resonancy.
Now, it's worth pointing out
that PNG, JPEG, and WebP don't
support these smaller
pixel formats as part
of their basic file structure,
meaning that at load time,
you're going to have to
set the inPreferredConfig
flag of your bitmap options
to whatever the target pixel
format is that you're
looking to use.
When the image is loaded, the
system will go load the data,
convert it to the
format on your behalf.
Just be aware though
that when it does this,
you may get some
extra processing
time as a result, which is
really important to note.
Performance is all
about trade offs.
Image memory size, visual
quality, and load times,
it's all things that you
have to balance perfectly
for your application to get
the best performance possible.
Of course, that's why you
need to check out the rest
of the Android performance
patterns content and also join
our Google+ community for great
tips on other developers on how
they balanced this
tricky equation.
So keep calm, profile your
code, and always remember,
perfmatters.